hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds this is ronnie
and ronnie put her son who was how old
is it at the time 17 17
17 through my training academy to learn
about property
even though you were planning on putting
him through university
and your daughter went through
university yeah both daughters
why did you choose to put josh your 17
year old son
through my property training academy and
pay ten thousand pounds for that
and not put him through university well
originally it was just to shut him up
really um
but he dragged me to a seminar
yeah and then i felt i had to apologize
to him
because he'd been going on about
property for ages yeah talking about me
you thought it was a bit and he had me
sold okay
so we brought you along to the event and
he's like i really want to do this you
put him through
let's have a chat with josh and see how
he's doing some months later
josh you were 17 years old when we met
yeah you started watching my youtube
videos from 16 years old
and your parents kindly let you go
through my training academy
how's it going really good really good
so
you've been now a member of the academy
for eight months yep you've done your
first
deal which was a put your money in pull
your money out
and how much money was left into the
deal 63 pounds dude that is ridiculous
yeah so effectively you bought a house
for 63 pounds
it's a dinner yeah it's the price of a
dinner you also have packaged and sold a
deal
yep started with no investor list no
knowledge about property just watched
grant cardone people on youtube
literally that's all i ever did all
right so tell me how did you get started
what made you want to get into property
where did that burning desire come from
so this goes really far back as far as i
can remember
always wanted to be in business i knew
that was the way to go wholeheartedly
knew that that's what you that's what
you got to do
and then i got really serious when i was
14. i read rich dad poor dad that got me
very inspired and then after that i just
started
watching like everybody grant cardone
robert kiyosaki
dan pena all these different business
moguls and uh influencers
and i was reading about i was reading
about very successful business people
from the past andrew carnegie
rockefeller ford
um basically everyone in think and grow
rich
and it just it it put me into that state
of mind of
it can be done and then i decided to
then
start to apply what i'd learned and how
couple of little out of a couple little
entrepreneurial ventures and then school
came gcses came around
i was purely focused on that then that
summer holiday
i had my prom and i had a family friend
who's very successful and he drove me to
prom in his lamborghini i remember when
i was sitting in that car
it was like i need to work now i need to
work
if i want this i gotta work and after
that
it just a full steam ahead literally
went went and i just haven't stopped
since
that's awesome man how did you come
across my youtube channel and
how did you get yourself to the crash
course and how did you manage to get
your parents to come
okay so to start off with how i found
your youtube channel
i was already reading robert kiyosaki in
grant cardone
i was doing a lot of research on them
and their industries that's american
property
i turned 16 and i realized i need to
look at the uk i'm not in america
and then i did the google search how to
invest in uk property
a couple of forums your videos came up i
remember watching you
i remember seeing you just shouting down
the camera this is how you do it this is
what you got to do
and i was like okay he's got the most
energy i got and i got to follow what
he's teaching
and um i was literally you know i binge
watched
your videos a lot i went through all of
them i tried to pick up everything i
took
notes um and it made me think like right
i'm watching the youtube now i need to
actually i need to meet this guy in
person
i remember i was speaking to my parents
because i i knew i wanted to get
involved in property i had
and i was really driven to do it i'd
done a lot of research on it
but when i was doing more due diligence
and i found you need to be 21 to invest
i was like okay i wait there i need to
do something
for the time being and i did i had
another
online business going on but i didn't
contribute i didn't put enough into it
because i was just
property obsessed i was obsessed with it
while i was doing while i was doing my
online business drop shipping
i couldn't think about anything else but
property i remember i decided like right
i'm just going to pull the plug in it
i'm just going to go for property
because i discovered that you know there
are things you could do exactly what
i've done
i've done biorefurbish refinance with
the guarantor i've also been able to
package a seller deal through through a
closed sourcer
so it's been creative it's thinking
outside of the box don't think one way
it's like if they can grow rich there's
a saying you know it's on the first
chapter three feet from gold
you're going to find one little bit of
success you're going to have a barrier
you're going to think there's nothing
left there
and then what you need to do is you need
to you need to look deeper you need to
look more don't just pack up and go home
you need to look further expand
and then you're gonna you're gonna find
that success and that's exactly what
happened
i needed to then bring my parents along
to the event because i i knew
for them that it would it would get them
along as well
and i took i brought my mom to a seminar
she already said
she was sold she was she was driven for
it that's all she wanted to do
my dad as well then we then then we
decided to bring my dad on
my dad's the man of the house my
everything goes through my dad
so it was literally like okay how do we
how do you persuade how do i persuade
dad to get involved in this brought him
onto the crash course
and he just said right you okay i'm
gonna get you on the training
i was like what you see that's not
that's not like you my sister said
that's not like you
he said well if you've got to do it
you've got to do it and from there
just my family supported me it's it's
it's played such a big role and it's
allowed us to achieve what we
what we've got now and full in the
foreseeable future
so you read rich dad porter you're 14
years old yeah
and again that's a crazy thing to do
because most 14 year olds
wouldn't be like i'm gonna read a book
that's got nothing to do with my studies
i mean that's strange yeah so you
obviously have some
weird kind of desire to be successful in
business that most 14 years probably
didn't have i don't know
i think one thing that you see in a lot
of young people is they want to do it
yeah and i say myself you really want to
do it but you
don't know how you're going to do it
yeah you see the big goal you see
the rolls royce you see the ferrari you
see the watches do you see this
this whole abundance of riches are awake
that are waiting for you
yeah but you don't know how to get there
and i think one of the things that helps
a lot is when you
when you pick up the knowledge you're
going to pick up the knowledge very
slowly
and it's not going to be right there in
front of your face the secret to making
a million it's not going to say
here's a million here's how to do it you
have to figure it out yourself it's a
bit like the book think and grow rich
the secret the secret to thinking and
growing rich it doesn't say it on the
first page nor does it say it on the
last page yeah it's in the book you have
to discover it itself and if you're
ready
if you are ready for it it will show
itself in front you know what i think
you are
and i might be wrong tell me if you
think i'm wrong you are the
prodigy or the makeup of what happens
when someone
who's hungry gets the knowledge reads
the books
attends the seminars and then takes
massive action at the same time
that's what happens and it's really
interesting to see that tell me the
story
josh of how you managed to
drag your dad along it was your dad
right yeah
how did you manage to drag him down to
the crash course i know now
um you're both your parents your mom and
your dad unbelievable people like you
are
very fortunate to have people in your in
your family in your life
that support you in the way that they
support you in terms of believing in you
not giving it you want to play not
giving you loads of money but just
giving you opportunities and supporting
you like
what happened how did you end up at a
crash course who did you come with
tell me the story i was going to go down
that traditional university route as
you know i was i was in the i was in the
mind of do i go uni do i do the academy
what sort of path do i take i remember
when i was speaking to my family
it was a there was more entertaining it
was more of a
it was more of a a little fad yeah you
know it's not it's not going to go on
but i remember when i took my mum to
this one event
she was absolutely like gone it was
she was mind blown and she was so dead
set on mind blown
at what just how it can be done it's not
that how property investing can be done
people think that it's a lot it's it's
simple it's not easy it's simple yeah
it's a simple process but it's
there's a lot of there's a lot of
hurdles that come there so when your mom
and i've spoke to your mom about this
but when she saw how property investment
worked and how
some of the strategies that you can do i
mean she actually said to me that she
was almost like sorry
he was almost like i'm sorry josh that i
didn't
listen to you i'm sorry that i didn't um
i didn't really take it seriously
yeah would that be fair to say yeah yeah
yeah that's a fair way
and then she was like all right fine
let's check out samuel leeds
well the thing is is i had the crash
calls booked as well okay i had the
crash course but for me and my parents
we're all going to go down together
and what we had is my dad came my mom
didn't come in the end but she was she
was already her mind she was sold
my dad came along my dad's same sort of
mindset and then when he was there
he saw that it can't be done and the
environment the environment is so
positive it said you can do it it's not
a
sign up now where you're gonna you're
gonna fail forever yeah
and we went in the d we went in the dfe
uh me and my mom went on the dfe
together that started to put us
it's sorry just just for anyone's
listening sure so you went on the deal
find the extravaganza
which is an advanced training program a
few thousand pounds
and it's kind of like the advanced
version where we teach you how to put
your power team together
you book a lot of viewings you book your
big day so that's what you did with your
mom correct
yeah okay and then what happened after
that we
so we started to look at what we want to
do what sort of strategies we
were going to pick up and then there we
thought about the account
we were looking at the academy we
weren't like we're going to do the
academy we were like we're going to do
the deep
we've done the crash course dfes all
we're going to do academy we don't
we let's use what we have now yeah and
then look later on
but then we thought about it even more
we saw the environment the network the
people
that all academy members there's there's
some piece of value that each academy
member holds
whether that's a trade they know some
knowledge maybe they they're an
accountant maybe they're a surveyor
whatever whatever value it is they hold
value and things as
in the academy environment all that
value
it really builds it it can play a part
in you as well
and you know what as well um it's funny
because
you did the academy it probably stung
it's a big commitment
but you ended up finding this little
house in hull yeah
so talk to me about the figures and how
you found that so found it on right move
did you find it yeah okay and we were so
i was
starting to get involved in deal
sourcing and i was playing my big day
so for this big day we viewed eight
houses in total
and we went down we looked at all of
them in they're all very good
the one that caught our eye the most was
this one that we went for
they wanted forty five thousand pounds
for the house highly motivated seller
the house needed uh worked on to it i
was looking for the greatest house that
there was the greatest house
why because it's the work that could be
done to it
you can do a lot to the house yeah and
also by you finding the worst houses
you're benefiting the two it's number
one yourself you're
you're building your portfolio also
you're bringing good houses to the
market
you're providing good housing for people
and for some people
that that's what that's what they want
and you've provided it for them and i
guess the thing is
if you can find a house that has a
problem yeah and you can
fix that problem you're going to push
the value up right exactly
so firstly because i know that's what
you did so we're going to go we're going
to go through what happened so firstly
it's on for 45.
you managed to buy it for how much 39
995.
pretty good and did you put the offer in
yeah i did but dude honestly you're 17
at the time
a lot of 17 year olds they wouldn't even
have the nerve
to pick up the phone and put forward an
offer like how
anyway we'll we'll go back to that i
mean confidence-wise though
where did this confidence come from you
know i don't i don't think i have an
answer to it i think it's just doing it
you just do it yeah that that is
literally it it's
it sounds the thing is and i i thought
about it myself we were just having a
chat about this you know certain things
how you conduct
certain parts of business you think
there's some sort of secret
structure or algorithm to it it's not
it's just simply doing it yeah if you're
doing it just not caring what other
people say i think
because most people wouldn't want to do
that they'd be scared to pick up the
phone they'd be scared of getting
rejected they'd be scared of
how they might look or how they might
come across yeah but actually you're
saying no i need to get it at this price
for it to work yeah okay so and by the
way
i always say when i'm when i'm teaching
even if you can't buy the property
you've got no money you can't get a
mortgage
if you can find good deals everything
else will just come through
yeah do you believe that i do i do after
after seeing it with my own isaac yeah
because i think one of the reasons
people are scared to go out and find
properties is because they think well
what happens if i put an offer on a
property that's accepted
but i can't buy it because i've not got
the money but actually it's a case of
well you can raise the money you can
joint venture on it
you can package it and sell it to
somebody if you can find if you can
become valuable
as a 17 year old or however older if you
can become valuable and you can find
good deals then the money all the
investors
will just come you know that's what i
always say and and before we talk about
how you funded the deal and how that
happened and how you
structured that um a little bit of
backstory so i met you at the crash
course
i remember bumping into you and your dad
yeah yeah and you came and what did you
ask me when you came
up to me i was a bit nervous about the
question because i thought is it is it a
stupid question
but i remember coming up to you i was
like i'm 17.
i just got started property what the
hell do i do i don't know what i'm doing
yeah you're just like joint ventures
source deals that's it that's all that
you need do that and then the rest will
follow on
source deals package joint venture with
people
you were standing with your dad at the
time yeah and i remember your dad
from memory he was kind of like excited
proud of you the fact that you were even
there and you brought him along
up for this but a little bit skeptical
maybe a little bit ooh
yeah i don't know is that is that fair
to say i i uh
yeah yeah i guess so yeah okay so you
were kind of like
i'm ready i'm pumped but i don't know
what to do exactly
yeah you know so so anyway so that was
today i then met you again
i think when you just joined the academy
this time with your mom
so we were at the dfe we were looking to
join the academy we came here
you you had a chat with us specifically
about the academy what did i say to you
look if you want to if you want to if
you want to do it do it
but be aware that did i pressure sell
you no
no you didn't yeah yeah you just had to
chat with us and just let us have a
think about it yeah
i love pressure selling people there
in fact after you joined the academy did
you try and pay for
additional stuff no no no just you did
you did you you said to me like i think
i need to pay for some more mentoring oh
yeah yeah we did have a chat yeah and
what did i say
you don't need it i said don't do that
you're going to get
everything from within the academy
you're going to get mentoring coaching
the courses
and if you want extra support go take
action
go get some deals and me and the
trainers will be attracted to you and
we'll come and we'll just do it for free
yeah
so you're now on the academy i met your
mum on the i met your mum at the dfe
sorry
yeah i met your mum at the dfe and you
registered for the academy
and when i met you and your mom i was
like i knew you were real serious at
this point you went from at the crash
course saying what do i do you know what
the heck and your dad's like
skeptical but wanting to see it happen
now fast forward a couple
a couple months you at the dfe with your
mom i'm like
yeah serious now got all the
foundational knowledge wanting to go
there
so i think i did advise do the academy
if you're gonna put the work in
if you're gonna roll your sleeves up
which you did so you went and put an
offer on this property
uh how much thirty thirty nine thousand
nine hundred ninety five
all right so just below forty thousand
and why did you do just below 40
stamp to avoid stamp juicer yeah because
you don't pay any stamp duty less than
40 grand
so you put in your 40 grand no stamp
duty
and then you spent how much on the
property uh so the refurb
okay we're going to the legal side of it
yeah the legal costs were
984 that was for the paper that was for
the legal paperwork yep then we paid 350
pounds for a survey to get it checked
out cool
refurb work was four hundred and 7480
five so in total how much went in uh it
was forty eight thousand eight hundred
and thirteen
including literally refurb tax no no
there's no tax uh legal fees survey
everything yeah cool i'm gonna ask you
about financing it in a minute how you
got the money to do that which we'll
talk about sure
then you refinanced it and what was the
new
value of the property 65 000.
that's incredible so you buy for 39.99
you spend a little bit on it total in
money including everything's like 48
something
and then you refinance it for 65 grand
75
loan to value yeah meaning that you're
leaving in
63 pounds into the deal yeah which is
the price
of a dinner technically bought a house
for 63 pounds
and then your mortgage 75 percent lend
of a mortgage what's your mortgage what
are your
the interest payments uh 97 pounds 97
pounds
and you've uh already got the re-value
in
and you've got tenants looking and how
much is it on for the market so
in the area you can get 425 pounds to
475.
yeah with the standard of the work that
we've done we've been able to get the
top end of the rent which is
475 and at the moment with the letters
agent we've had
we have had some interest in the
property yeah uh so hopefully we should
have a tenant coming very soon
great that's all how long have you been
on the market uh it's been on the market
for just two weeks
okay cool and you've got interest you've
got people we've got we've got people
calling in so
as far as the letting students know it's
all good it's all green lights
okay so awesome deal and as i said a
moment ago
you find the deal everything else comes
into place now
you finance this correct me if i'm wrong
so your parents
who you got down to the crash course you
know your mom is on the academy she dead
on the academy too
no your mom's on the academy they put
the money in
yeah right but they've pulled the money
out so from their perspective they put
the money in they pulled the money out
so so they're not down financially
correction they're down 63 pounds
but from your point of view you found
the property
you pulled your folks in on the whole
business anyway yeah like
yes you've not done it alone yes you're
not self-made because no one's self-made
but like in my in my perspective i think
you've
pretty much like single-handedly kind of
made this thing happen
which for us which for for 18 18 year
old i think he's just ridiculous
and for people watching this because the
thing is your mind will always go to an
excuse
i know that with people watching this
and i go oh well my parents
wouldn't give me the money it's all
right for him you know or well
my uncle or whatever didn't give me rich
dad poor dad or my
and people always try and find excuses
but the bottom line is you came
to the crash course as a teenager with
no money with parents
who aren't like rolling in or anything
but just you know you got them in on the
vision
yeah and i mean i mean what would your
advice be to a young person watching
this
to anyone to anyone who's around like my
age
yeah just do it do it but get the prof
like get training for it
i think one of the biggest mistakes that
you can make at your age is taking that
financial risk
and messing up big time and then all it
does is yes you're gonna you're gonna
come back from it eventually
but in your mind you're you're
never gonna go back for it you're gonna
say it doesn't work it's not proven
it's just that it's just someone got
lucky so get get the professional get
the professional help get the advice for
it
and also try to another thing is try to
surround yourself with like-minded
people
who know who are in the same industry as
you try to speak to them because for
some people
what might not mean anything to you it
means something to someone else
and vice versa you might have a piece of
value that for someone who's starting
out in the industry
that could save them a lot so definitely
try to try to surround yourself
communicate with people okay what advice
would you give
because i think personally bringing in
parents or family members if i'm
advising a 16 17 18 year old
it's really helpful if you can get other
people in
family members they might have a bit
more experience if they've got a little
bit of finance or equity or whatever
yeah if you can get them in on the
vision rather than saying oh can you
lend me some money and they're like what
for oh i want to do something property
investment thing and i want to join this
academy
and they're going to think it's real
risky yeah
but if you can pull them in on the
vision so they can see it for themselves
like your mom did
when she was just like oh my goodness i
can see it this makes sense
i think that is amazing if you could do
that now not everybody's going to be
able to do that maybe some people's
parents would just be like no i'm not
coming to a crash course
it's stupid in which case maybe try and
find someone else to bring
in but how do you what advice would you
give how do you get people to come in on
the vision
just show them the proven results and
show them the proven results that's
i mean that's what i did i showed i
showed my family my family
already wanted to get into the industry
um but show
whoever whoever you're trying to
persuade to get into it just show them
what
what can be done that it can be done
that's it yeah then you got to let them
wait it's going to take them some
it's going to take them some time to to
take it down and try to
understand everything but eventually
they will then end up saying like yes
let's go for it
because i think ultimately most parents
do want the best for their kids
yeah yeah like most parents you know
they want their kids to be
comfortable financially they want to be
happy healthy that's pretty much every
parent
yeah the thing is some parents might
think
in order to be financially comfortable
and happy they
need to go to uni they need to get a job
they need to so in their mind that's
what
the kid needs so so it's almost about
said actually there is an alternative
route
which is a very good alternative route
which is very
um you know financially viable that
works
i mean would you would you agree uh yeah
i would i would agree i would agree i
think one thing that you have to
i think one thing that like like you've
already just said parents want what's
best for their kids
but also at the same time it's also what
you what your parents knows
is what works but the thing is is when
you when you
going back to what i said when you try
to show that it can be done
then you just you just have to be
patient and wait for it yeah i think
that's something that i had like massive
like both of my sisters went to
university
and they're very successful the two of
them they're very very successful
they're very they're in very good jobs
but for me it just wasn't for me and
even then when you have other people
around that who've even been to
university or whatever sort of
life route they've taken even those
people you show them the results as well
and then they'll persuade that person
that original person you're trying to
show
that's like what my sister did my
sisters did when um when i was trying to
show my family about property and you
know it can be done even at my age
my sisters were the first people to say
look like let him do it
if if he's saying that it could be done
then let him do it and let's see what
happens
yeah so and i how grateful are you for
your parents
stepping in and helping you out because
i mean it's a big deal
no no no number can ever repay
what like repay it it's
it makes me um it makes me think
sometimes like really deeply like
they've really supported it they really
do they really do believe
in in me they they believe in what can
be done
yeah and also at the same time it it's
allowing me to
give them what what they want as well
the things that they've worked so hard
for
it's now able to put us on that fast
track route
to give that for them and i remember
just saying to your dad at the crash
course i remember just saying
respect just for being here you know
just for coming along
and saying i'm going to be open-minded
for my kid because my kid keeps banging
on about this guy on youtube
like i'll come along just to see like i
think respect because some people
wouldn't do that
and i know for me my stepdad um you know
he didn't give me any money
a bit like in your situation a little
bit the structure of the deal was
different
he um he hosted my first property
because i was too young to get a
mortgage yeah
yeah and in the same way you know your
folks actually they're not down
financially you know they've put they've
put the money into this property they've
hosted it you've got a company that
you've set up together
yeah which is awesome you've managed to
refinance it and pull the money out
but i think their shared belief in you
and in the system is really
really admirable so i'm i'm delighted
and honored to know you and
and your family um tell me about your
other deal because you did a
another joint venture where you packaged
and sold a deal but you didn't have any
investors
you didn't need any money for the deal
how did that work
uh so same sort of thing our patch our
patch um
is hull and we had another big day we
were going down to
view a couple of properties and view the
by refurbishing finance deal we were
going to take a look at the work and see
what's been done
and we literally found this found this
property on right move again gave the
agents a call see if they'd be
interested in the
if would offer they said yeah they could
consider it went down there took a look
at it
it's the turnkey hmo no work is needed
at all it's a six bedroom
it's doing 350 pounds of room which is
doing
2100 a month rent yeah by all six rooms
no work is needed at all literally no
work and
we i was able to negotiate the price
down so originally wanted 155
000 i was able to get it down to a
hundred and
thirty eight thousand okay and after
that
looked at the lettings agents got a
lettings agent there to
to look at the property they said that
they will happily let it out and the
the achievable rent was the figures that
were that were rigidly put in our um
original numbers that we were doing yeah
and uh pass it on to
a co-sourcer okay so people are gonna
now be thinking what what the heck a
co-sourcer
so you found a deal yeah now you didn't
have the money for the deal
no you didn't have any investors for the
deal yeah yeah you just literally
took your skills that you learned on the
training on the academy on the deal
finding extravaganza
you went through them you did your
market research you negotiated the deal
you just did what needed to be done and
then they said yes and you think well i
haven't got
an investor for this i haven't got the
money for this so you co-deal sourced it
which means what
uh so passed it on to another deal
sorcerer okay so you found another deal
saucer where did you meet this deal
saucer from
uh it's another academy member another
academy member and you said hey
i've got this deal it's a good deal and
i know what a good deal is because i'm
smart and i've been trained
have you got any investors for it and
then what happened
uh they were they were happy to sell it
they did they did have investors how
much do they sell it for interested
uh 3 500. and how much you get
a third a third okay so they're a little
bit stingy but it's okay
so you made about how much uh 1200 1200
pounds
so but still 12 1 200 pounds
for just finding a deal using your
skills without any investors
it just shows that find the deals and
the rest will kind of happen
yeah and now you're 18 you've just not
turned what was your birthday uh 10th of
june 10th of june so you turned 18
last month yeah and and and now you're
full time in property is that right yeah
yeah full time and that's what has you
on when it's wednesday because i'm
thinking okay you've only done two deals
but you're full-time your full-time
property now so what's next uh
so we've got a couple of goals me and my
family have yeah um one of the ones for
sourcing is
i'm aiming to do one deal a week now
yeah i started to build the list and the
list is building
and by the way if anyone watching this
wants to go on your list and find your
deals yeah they've got to go on your
website
which is what uh jonahsourcing.com
jonahsourcing.com yeah
j-o-n-a sourcing okay cool and i'll
leave i'll leave a link in the
description so people can check that out
okay so you're going to be aggressively
growing the deal sourcing business yeah
what else so that's one deal a week uh
me my family as well
we're still looking in brrs now we want
to we want to take it a step further we
want to do a bigger deal
each time so what do you mean by that
and a big deal each time what do you
mean so you just so you just pulled all
the money out from this little deal yeah
so we've done we've done a little deal
yeah we want to take something that's a
little bit bigger
and then after that we we're going to go
we're going to we're going to take it
so you just slowly get bigger and bigger
and bigger with the deal
yeah as you already said you don't want
to rush into something correct don't
rush
take it take it slow take it calculate
correct that that is the way to do it
but it's really funny though for anyone
that might misunderstand that advice
take it slow take it calculated with
your slow pound stuff
with your investments with your activity
to building your business
you got to go fast you got to go hard
and you got to take ridiculous action
which is what you're doing yeah
so like if you've got some money to
invest yeah don't rush into investing it
crazy you've got to find the right deal
but you have got to rush it like crazy
to looking at properties
yeah you've got to be taking you've got
to be taking mad action what's the uh
what's the training be like what's it
like in the academy member
the number one the training it's more
it's worth more in value than what his
price tag is
also it's not just the training that
you're getting on it you're also getting
the network you're getting the ability
to
communicate with other trainers like
yourself uh you're able to find joint
venture partners like already said as
well at the academy
each person in the academy has an
individual skill that can benefit you
and you have a skill that can benefit
them
yeah so using using the network in the
academy like um
you know there's some people that are
surveyors or some people that no
builders are some people that are
accountants
all these different skills you might not
have a power team when you start a
property
but when you go through something like
the academy and you communicate with
people
then you you could potentially have a
full-on unstoppable power team
yeah that's awesome so so with the
academy how did it work then like
your parents kind of almost put you
through the academy
so i originally it was university like
harry said that's what they were gonna
do put you through university yeah and
you begged them to do the academy
instead
it was a hard battle but i won it okay
because because again
like people people will say that people
will say
it's all right for you your parents put
you through samuel's training but
parents put kids to university all the
time
yeah yeah so so you and and and you
for you is either a choice of you know
are you going to go through una
are you going to go through the academy
yeah and people don't see it as an
option
but it's interesting to see what happens
when and and don't get me wrong and
you'll be the first to say this
you've got to buy a lot of work in right
one thing that i say with the academy
when i say it
i say it wholeheartedly is
it does it it's ten it's ten thousand
pounds right that's a lot of money
especially to an 18 euro that's a lot of
money but what you need to do the
academy is
that's not your ticket to the riches
you're not going to
join the academy six months later a
rolls royce appears at your front door
yeah i know i know it's a bit that's a
bit extreme but it's what i mean is
that yeah you have to put in what you
put in you get out yeah
all that the what the academy does is it
gives you the knowledge and it saves you
five to ten years of mistakes rejections
all these different things that add up
to your success
yeah it just answers your questions
there by you if there's a
is there something that you don't
understand the academy will answer that
for you yeah so that
three years down the line when you do
that specific strategy that has that
that originates that question that you
want to ask you're not going to discover
it by messing up on it yeah
i think that's so important josh because
it's the same as you go to harvard
business
university and you spend oh tens and
tens of thousands of pounds
you're not gonna suddenly become a
millionaire businessman
no you're gonna go you're gonna go
through the training and you're gonna
have the tools
yeah but each individual has to then put
the
put the practice in and implement what
they what what they're doing and that's
what you've been doing you've been
working hard
how many properties did you have to view
to get that first one so originally with
that one
it was about 15 15 15 yeah and again if
you view 14 houses and they're all no
good and they don't work out
natural human reactions to say this
doesn't work but originally
it was it was eight in hull and then the
rest were because we were still trying
to keep our options open
yeah we were looking a little bit
ourselves accommodation a couple of
rental rounds yeah sure so we were
looking around but i think when we
originally saw that one we went to we
went to hull we
saw these brr deals yeah it just shows
like
that is the strategy that that we want
to go for yeah so
but i like i like students like you
because when you join the academy you're
almost comparing it to university so
you're like i've got university as an
option
yeah i've got the academy as an option
when you when some people join the
academy
you know and we have to warn these
people off because they do they think
i'll join the academy and then six weeks
later
i'll just be rich and all my money
problems will be over he's like
no when you go to university people in
their mind they think
long term yeah i'm gonna go to uni i'll
spend a couple few years there
i'll graduate then i'll go and get a job
and the university will give an
opportunity to get a job
then i'll work my way up that's how
people think yeah and the academy is no
different
you register for the academy you get the
training you get your first deal
then you work your way up and this is a
long term game it's not get rich quick
it's get wealthy over a period of time
and it can be months for some people and
it can be years for other people it
depends on
a bit of luck and a bit of how much you
work and a bit of
natural ability as well but ultimately
this is a long-term game and what you've
done
how long have you been on the academy uh
just about
just hit eight months eight months yeah
and a few months of that's been locked
down
yeah have your support being good
throughout lockdown support's been great
one thing that you have to look at with
done is you are you are gonna
you're not gonna feel that great in
lockdown everyone's had it yeah if you
haven't had it then you're lying
yeah but with but especially with things
like the webinars the calls
um and and just just need the network
that the academy has
you okay you're not going to feel you're
not going to feel you're great it's as
it as if yeah there's live events
but it's still going to put you in that
position of other people are doing
something i need to do something
otherwise i'm just wasting the three
four months
and even if it's not catching loads of
deals you can use this time for your
mindset you can use this time for
reading
i've literally i've just been reading
books the entire the entire lockdown
that's awesome bro
and you're going to be coming back to
many crash courses i hope
yeah yeah for the energy the networking
i'm going back
you'll see me there a lot so if people
want to connect with you they're
probably best to jump on a crash course
they'll see you there
soon you'll be on stage bro you'll be
you'll be teaching you'll be
you'll be you'll be doing my job what
would your
best advice be to someone that's saying
i'm prepared to put the work in i'm
prepared to put the time in i'm compared
to a card
but what are my best steps what are my
next steps what do i need to do what
would your advice be
from my experience and i'd also take
into consideration i've been in a really
good position with my family being very
supportive yeah sure but
find find your opportunity know how to
discover an opportunity
yes opportunities majority of the time
they come across as curses but they're a
blessing in the skies
i i believe that completely
try to find your opportunities there
yeah and i'm saying that from
and i'm saying that from even just
getting on on the
on the track just getting on the race
shot to do it it's not necessarily
closing deals but the first thing that
you want is you
your success starts with a thought so
try to find
that thought and then once you find that
thought
try to create a plan and then execute it
yeah that's so
i think i love what you say about find
opportunities most people find problems
most people find reasons and i said that
earlier that people would be thinking
but
my parents wouldn't have done that
although i didn't get the opportunity to
go on samuel's academy i didn't get
rather than finding what you haven't got
and finding your problems we all got
problems
you've got to find actually what's my
opportunity
if you're living in this country you're
already a massive head start from a lot
of people
i i say i say it a lot we live we live
in a country that people
lose their lives trying to get to yeah
so don't waste don't waste the
opportunity
this this little island that run it's
already it's already one opportunity
yeah sure so take full advantage of it
yeah because you're in a you're
you're in a position that's better then
and that's
that goes for a lot of other countries
like united states and germany
and and and holland great great
countries yeah and again
you know if there's free property
investors crash courses going on all the
time that's an opportunity people say oh
i've got this problem
have you even been have you even have
you even shown up
you know yeah um what's the um what's
been the hardest point
so and that and and the hardest point
within the academy or over property in
general just just in your whole journey
over the last however many months it's
been whether it be in property on the
training side just what's been the heart
have you ever felt like quitting or has
it been any moments we've just thought
this is not going to happen
i think it's i think i think it's trying
to
understand that no is good yeah the more
knows you get the closer you are to a
yes
yeah and i think that's one thing that
you need to understand is
that you're not gonna get success is an
instant you don't you don't wake up
the next day and you're you're you're
multi-millionaire it goes there's a lot
of there's a lot of heartaches that go
through and even i know my deals are
very small but
the amount of stress that is caused it's
it's hard at the moment but you know
it's going to pay off like sitting here
speaking to you right now this is this
is a part of the success
that these deals have created so
overcoming overcoming the the crappy
feeling that you're gonna have
you're gonna have a crappy feeling but
if you feel that it's good because
you're doing something
yeah if you if you didn't feel this way
you're not doing enough and you don't
care about it enough
your goals mean nothing to you it's just
something that you have in your head or
it's a screenshot if you have in your
phone
it doesn't mean anything to you when
you're trying to take the action and be
honest with yourself
you when you know you're taking actual
like serious action
and nothing's coming from it it's
because your opportunity it hasn't come
for you yet you're ready for it but it
hasn't come
it hasn't come to you yeah so you once
again going back to opportunities
know how to know how to discover them
because they
they come completely not in the way that
they should learn that's really powerful
and i think as well
getting used to hearing no yeah getting
used to being rejected
because it's gonna happen you know you
want to be successful how did it feel
though
getting the keys because i know i spoke
to your parents and i said look this is
josh's house
you know this is josh found it we came
in on it for sure but we've pulled our
money out this is josh's house this is
his thing
as a teenager having keys in your hand
to a house that you can say that's my
house
yeah i mean how how did that make you
feel
just like is this actually happening
that's the thing is it actually
happening because your
your first deal was your baby yeah that
that's i think
i don't know how you feel about it but
for me i don't i don't think i'd ever
want to give up i wouldn't want to give
away the deal
dude i've still got my first house yeah
the one that i bought when i said it i
still got that
and it's doubled in value yeah you don't
want to give it away because it's so
important it's like where wherever
you're going to be in 10 years 20 years
you're still going to remember that's my
first deal yeah
and i think it's a it's a very powerful
thing and it makes you when you look at
it
i'm not i've only done one but i'm going
to do more
more in the future you're still going to
look back at that first thing and think
the amount of heartache that that gave
me but what it's created
yeah so it feels and i'm saying that
like i'm looking years in the future but
you do think when you look at you think
i'm holding these keys how many keys is
this going to be in my hand in
12 months in two years five years so
that's awesome man
and and the the mortgage payments are
like 90 something pound a month
the rent's going to be you say about 475
but even at 450.
that's good profit in that yeah some
good monthly cash flow
it's only small but you pulled all your
money out exactly bought a house to 63
pounds
yeah and it's gonna make you it's gonna
make you probably two or three hundred
pounds profit a month
yeah yeah which is absolutely insane and
you managed to keep the refurb out under
the refurb take
uh refurb was about two months two
months yeah
and did that go smoothly with any
problems uh it went it went it went
pretty it went pretty
any tips on managing a refurb for the
teenagers listening they're gonna be
managing refurbs
nothing nothing really specifically i
think just just keep it just keep a
close eye on it and
communicate with your builders you had
like a little whatsapp group going right
yeah yeah
that was one thing you need that yeah
try to even if your builders aren't
going to do it then do that and just
keep in contact with them yeah
constantly
you don't need to call them every single
day because that's just going to annoy
them but
communicate with them oftenly just say
like where do you find the builders from
another academy member there we go back
going back to the network and the power
of the
link man the people people say josh they
say you know oh the information's for
free online i'm not going to pay for my
training
yeah what do you think of that look you
can
you can do that but you're going to make
a lot of mistakes yeah that
don't get me wrong you're still you're
still gonna reach success at one point
but that's potentially five five years
five to ten years of
yeah halts just pure if you didn't go
bankrupt first yeah
to say um education's expensive
but mistakes are more expensive yeah and
if you think education's too expensive
then you should try ignorance
you know what i i do say it though if
you're serious about it enough
yeah this isn't just a little i hate
using the word side hustle but this
isn't just a little side hustle
sure to make max maybe a couple thousand
pounds a
a month then if you're if you really
want it
then take the training and do it and
you've got to see it like university you
don't go to university and just go let's
see what happens after a few months oh
yeah i still joke about it with my
sisters my sisters go on about uni and
stuff and i say well
mine's the academy so i can't really
relate to your conversation yeah
right but yeah and you can do both we've
got we've got people that are doing
university they're on the academy but
i'm really really pleased to know you
i'm
really pleased to see that your deal has
gone well um
you've been a real um asset to the
academy you've been an asset to your
family it's great getting to know your
parents as well
and chat with you guys so look forward
to seeing you flourish and prosper over
the coming months and years
and thanks so much for coming on the
show and inspiring my audience
respect man